c'est officiel on connaît le visage de
la nouvelle miss france
il se trouve parmi les trente miss
régionales qui viennent d'être révélés
et dans la sélection il y à du du côté
de miss provence et miss réunion on note
le sourire qui risque de faire chavirer
le coeur de plus d'un dentiste
comme chaque année la miss fait qu'elle
est appelée aussi dans le jargon la mise
dans la région gagne une fois sur deux
et annabelle varane une miss très web
qui avait tout de même créé la polémique
à cause de la renommée de son frère
raphaël dans la catégorie j'ai bien
envie de visiter votre région cet été on
appelle miss alsace miss rhône-alpes et
miss languedoc roussillon et enfin voici
un général pour toutes les autres mises
qui voleront peut-être très bientôt la
couronne à maeva coup ça quand on attend
ce jeu sera les sous doués en vacances
sur ces 8 ch peut le voir il faut alors
les soit miss dévoiler les chéris
pour vous quel est votre favorite
valérie bénaïm bout c'est qu'il y en ait
deux mois c'est miss tahiti mx langues
mais c'est au moment où je m'estime ça
oui beau des liens à huy a enlevé le
reste faut lever le verrou celle à vous
la voyez très très joli corps alors
attention benjamin castaldi miss tahiti
vraiment juste très bon c'est vrai mais
c'est pas mon délire mais vous ouvrirez
votre délire face aux horreurs arrêté
c'est pas un seul écran capable
on va voir si bien très bien ici et là
j'avais dit un jour vous verrez que la
bd on va voir mais l'a pour l'instant je
suis calme mais un jour tu nous diras en
france je suis enfant alors vous c'est
qui ces miss lorraine tma 21 ans
militaire comme son papa magnifique une
amie de la famille de facto je vous le
dis franchement c'est les votes
[Rires]
si les ventes ne sont pas truquées là
bien sûr gagner alors je vous le dis
c'est une amie de la famille de fans
c'est votre favori de ces deux nous
rejoignent et donnez-nous votre favori
la bombe histoire sur les voies tout
voilà alors jean-michel miss réunion a
alors vas l'avoir bénéfique les gens
savent tous les réunionnais les
réunionnaises vide avec bah oui mais
calmez vous quand même alors des liens
il avait vu passer pas au format
catalogue ce alors non mais arrêtez moi
tu vois je me sens très belle mais c'est
pas des manuels ce qui vous à moi c'est
miss poitou charentes marion sow
coliques parce que
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors l'une des magnifiques moi c'est
pas mon délire et jolie et elle fois que
j'ai vu ça j'ai lu l'info la bombe
devrait elle il m'a dit si peu plus la
région gérée et miss provence
voilà un beau sourire c'est pas pour me
dire la libraire aller maintenant
depuis qu'un savoura non alors c'est la
possession et le botox avenir proche
avec miss provence j'espère peut-être
réitéré cédé un petit cochon vous c'est
un petit creux s'est invité à la radio
l'avait accepté cela alors même quand on
invite des gens les accepte aussi merci
vous avez fait assez de mal comme ça
miss ile-de-france et embrasse tous les
parisiens après jean de coucher avec sa
belle c'est pas mon délire chien de
l'année qu'on la déteste c'est le cas
match mais cousineau bébé leurs photos
sont assez rares photos sont assez oui
bah comme vous comme votre gueule et
isabelle louis et de refoulement miss
pays de loire
d'accord mais c'est la loire s'est mis
pays de la loire
l'hôtesse au puy du fou on sent coupable
les unes que les autres
on ne sait qui je suis vous êtes des
glaces mais c'est vous rigolez pour ça
[Rires]
elles sont sublimes
vous débutez vous étiez petits gosses
ils se détacheront l'instant c'est haïti
qui se détache mais il ya des triades et
révèle à 1 me soit touchante magnétique
oui c'est pas un grand cru les mérites
aucun cas moi j'ai franchement c'est pas
mon délire mais franchement elle pour
elles sont traitées mais voilà et bravo
est les braves au concours miss ronde
qui ont fait un travail excellent